las palabras del líder supremo de la
revolución ayer en las que dice que irán
podría enriquecer uranio a un 60 por
ciento para su programa de energía
nuclear pacífico como ellos lo llaman
también tienen que leerse en ese momento
en el cual tanto eeuu como los otros
países firmantes e irán están en un
momento en el cual podrían recuperar el
acuerdo nuclear y así están intentándolo
por la vía diplomática sin embargo el
líder supremo le recordó que ellos no
están buscando armas nucleares que así
lo sabían eeuu como israelí que se
hubiera querido hacerlo lo hubieran
intentado hace muchísimo tiempo esto
sucede en un momento cuando irán se
retira hoy de ese protocolo adicional
del tratado de no-proliferación lo que
significa que los inspectores de la
organización internacional de energía
atómica no podrán hacer visitas
relámpago a estas instalaciones
nucleares pero lo que sí lograron
negociar durante el fin de semana con el
director de esta organización es que los
inspectores sigan en iran y puedan
seguir haciendo visitas esporádicas sin
embargo no en la misma dimensión que lo
hacían antes
tampoco tendrá acceso a esas cámaras que
están ubicadas dentro de las plantas
nucleares aunque sí tendrán acceso a
esas grabaciones y en los próximos tres
meses logran llegar a un acuerdo